three-two-one see BASE jumping is
already the most dangerous sport in the
world then you also mixing that with big
mountain skiing you combining full
intensity sports in an unforgiving
environment the risk factor is
definitely pretty high
[Music]
hi I'm a teenager Oh aka super Frenchie
I'm a pro big mountain skier and
professional BASE jumper and I like to
put this two scores together ski BASE
jumping is skiing of a massive cliff
that would be too big to survive and
land safely so you use a parachute I
like to use my parachute as a tool to
ski things that otherwise could not ski
I've been ski BASE jumping for ten years
and the last ten years have been filled
with a lot of fun adventures I ski base
jump of the Eiger and also the
Matterhorn in Switzerland heavens 11 in
Telluride I'll run an avalanche by ski
BASE jumping of a 650 lifts that's a
pretty cold day fear is a is an
interesting thing your instinct tells
you okay stop right there don't go any
further this is the end of the world
right there this thing is gonna kill you
this is the moment where you have to
take over and be know I'm gonna jump up
this thing and then you come flying off
this cliff things get even faster an
ariana grande's coming straight at you
it feels like he's gonna eat you there
the moment you're living it caught it
all that time turn back look at where
you came from and then realized that
something super cool just happened look
big mountain skiing and BASE jumping is
not forgiving I've definitely lost a lot
of friends over the years I've almost
died myself several times you got to be
on it you gotta do the right thing if
you want to do it for a long time
hey I'm alive I'm not hurt we did it
we're all looking for happiness and some
people find happiness through balance
and monotony and routine in their life
and for me that's honestly my worst
nightmare
I seek happiness through intensity I
think that intensity can bring the best
out of people
[Music]